hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his work the Poetics Aristotle is
going to discuss three closely related
aspects of tragedies as he understands
them the way that they
ought to be and we typically call these
reversal recognition and suffering and
these are three important aspects that
apply to the most important Dimension or
aspect or part of tragedy as a whole and
that's what he calls plot or muthos
literally story so how is the story
being developed and he he begins this
discussion by telling us that there's
two different kinds of plots there's
simple plots and complex plots and
simple plots don't really make for good
tragedies why because they actually lack
the
structures the
aspects the the effects as well of
reversal and recognition so they don't
achieve what they're supposed to he says
I call Simple an action which is
continuous
in the sense defined and unitary but
whose transformation
the the metabossets the change that's
occurring lacks reversal and recognition
complex is one whose transformation
contains recognition or reversal or both
of these and we're going to talk a bit
about you know how this should take
place he also talks about the
possibility later on of mutual
recognition recognition at the same time
and of reversal and recognition being
connected together
within the plot so simple plots lack
this and suffer because of it and
complex plots have this so we'll look at
what these are in just a moment but
there is something I wanted to bring up
from considerably later in the book when
he's talking about four types of tragedy
and and types here is actually
translating a day so he's he's serious
about this these are this is a division
and then he goes on and he says there's
the complex whose Essence is reversal
and recognition right the the
uh whole of it lies in this and then
there's the kind rich in suffering heyda
pathetic and it uses for examples at the
Ajax which we still possess and the
ixian and then he talks about the
character based and then the fourth
being the simple and he says ideally you
should strive to have all of these
failing that the best and the most
especially in view of current censure of
The Poets meaning that people are
criticizing The Poets in in his own time
and so he thinks that the best kind of
tragedy is going to have reversal in
recognition this will be absolutely
Central to it but it's also going to be
rich in suffering it's going to be
pathetica and it'll have good characters
as well and there will be a overall
Unity to it so that said what are these
important aspects so he's going to
actually provide us with definitions or
characterizations of each one of these
so let's start with reversal which is
Peri potato something shifting as he
says it's a change so it's a metabola
this is a term that he's using over and
over here and that's also translated as
transformation this is Central in in a
plot things change you don't just simply
have repeating repeating repeating
because that's not a story a story has
to have things being different becoming
different in it so a change
to the opposite and here you know we've
got opposite direction literally it's
just aceto and non-tion into the
Opposites or the you know the contrary
right of events
um and this is interesting because the
the term here in Greek is not tone
pragmaton which we would expect if it is
events but rather the things that are
actually done
right coming from
the verb so these are closely connected
because pragmata and Praxis and and
prachin are all you know the same root
so these are the things that the people
in the plot are doing so it changed to
the opposite of events and he'll give
you some examples but we'll come back to
that in a moment let's talk about
recognition
says recognition as the very name
indicates is also a change metabole
from ignorance not knowing something
to uh knowledge of that thing right and
this happens quite a lot in these plays
ex agnoyas a snow scene right
so this is is quite important but then
it adds two other interesting
qualifiers to this so it's not just any
sort of learning something
recognition isn't say finding out that
you live in a certain postal ZIP code
and isn't that interesting because now I
can send a letter it's got to have more
going on there so the uh the change from
ignorance to knowledge leads to an
affective relational response it leads
to friendship philia right or to enmity
or we could say hatred
right so it's it's leading the
characters into taking positions in
relation to each other right and then
there's a third part
bearing on things that have to do with
prosperity or adversity so that is
things going well for you but there's an
element of chance there right
Deuce is the opposite of ew in Greek
meaning bad so bad fortune bad luck and
he actually uses the term
horizmenon there so it's not just in
relation to but defined by or restricted
to so that's what recognition is and
then he's you know talk about both of
those quite a bit and then uh towards
the end of this discussion
he says these are two components of the
plot reversal and recognition a third is
suffering and the term that he's using
there is just pothos which means emotion
or suffering or you know something like
a strong desire and in the the framework
of Greek tragedy what does this actually
mean he tells us that it is destructive
or painful action Praxis there so
somebody is doing something to somebody
or fate is doing something to somebody
and it is destructive
right meaning
corrupting damaging or uh
uh painful and he gives you some
examples of these public deaths deaths
that take place in public literally a
parent deaths right or uh Agony or
wounding or other such things he says
so that gives you an idea about what the
suffering aspect is let's come back to
the reversal so what are examples of
reversals
what happens in them so he says
um
for example in the Oedipus the person
who comes to bring Oedipus happiness and
intends to rid him of his fear about his
mother he affects the opposite by
revealing oedipus's true identity right
in the linkiest the one figure is let
off to die donaus follows with the
intention of killing him yet the upshot
of events is down house death and the
others survival so we have some sort of
thing happening contrary to our own
expectation
now if we actually knew all the the
matters behind the play then it wouldn't
be that much of a surprise to us and
we're going to talk about that in just a
moment
uh so that's reversal what about
recognition so we've got this important
change that's taking place and he says
that the finest recognition is one that
actually occurs simultaneously with
reversal for example in the Oedipus
right but there's other kinds as well
um could be in relation to inanimate and
even chance things it's also possible to
recognize someone has or has not
committed a deed but the one that is
most relevant to the plot and action is
the one described joint recognition and
reversal will yield either pity or fear
which is part of what tragedy is about
and then he says it's recognition
between people some cases involve only
the relation of one party to the other
when the other's identity is clear so
you're a guard and you know you belong
to the city everybody knows who you are
and somebody comes the door and you
think they're an enemy but they're
actually the long lost Prince of the
City or something like that right and
suddenly you recognize oh my gosh that's
who it is right that's recognition and
that happens with the characters
but it happens with us too the audience
or the readers of it he says in others
there's need for double recognition for
example if a Genia is recognized by
arrestees through the sending of the
letter but for if a Genia to recognize
his relation to herself required a
further recognition and Aristotle will
actually go on and and talk about
different sorts and effects of
recognition in a bit more detail there
but that's probably enough for talking
about all three of these and how they
work together now there is one other
massively important aspect of this
stress that he places on the plot and
the importance of these three elements
uh reversal recognition and suffering
now it doesn't apply quite so much to
the suffering explicitly but perhaps
implicitly we should read that in
at the very beginning
of this discussion we've seen that he
says that these elements recognition or
reversal should emerge from what he
calls the structure of the plot
tastes sustachios to mutho so a plot
already is a structure anyway right it's
a synthesis
it's a bringing things together now
we're looking at the very structure of
the plot how is it held together
Aristotle is a big critic of things that
don't really make sense and are just you
know thrown together in episodic manners
that haven't been adequately thought
through by the producer the poet
he tells us that what we want here is
that these elements should emerge from
it so that they occur or develop they
come into being from preceding events
right and there's a an important way he
he talks about this either from
necessity ex Anon case so necessity
means like if this happens well then
this has to happen too and this did
happen so now this is going to occur or
he doesn't say out of probability but in
accordance
with probability and the Greek for that
is using a different term right
katatos so akos is probability what is
likely what is believable what makes
sense in the circumstances and he's
going to tell us you know things about
this uh later on
um you know when it comes to the
different kinds of tragedy things need
to make sense with each other as we saw
he also talks about
um when you're writing a tragedy you're
aiming for what you want by means of the
awe-inspiring this is tragic and arouses
fellow feeling and he says this can
happen when a clever but Wicked person
is deceived or a brave or unjust person
is worsted why these things are probable
as Agatha John puts it and Harry says
something really quite interesting
they're probable because
it's probable many things should
infringe or go against
probability so the the probable is not
just like a big list of the things that
we consider probable with a bunch of
percentages sometimes weird events are
going to happen that's part of the realm
of probability but it's Gotta make sense
it's got to be connected with the things
that happened before not just chance as
Aristotle says or pure luck or things
happening in a certain way although he
does actually at one point tell us that
we can have
chance events that seem as if they were
faded you know like a statue falling on
somebody killing them when that statue
is somehow connected with that person
it's a random event but it doesn't
appear to be completely random to us so
these elements uh reversal recognition
if you want them to really work you
can't just throw them in there
willy-nilly they've got to fit the plot
you know there has to be a structurally
situating of them and we can even say
the suffering perhaps needs to make some
sense in order for us to respond to it
emotionally in the way that Aristotle
talks about namely uh in terms of fear
and pity but also in terms of feeling a
sense of awe and a fellow feeling
philanthropia which are all different
passions that he talks about so these
three aspects very very important to the
plot if you want to have a successful
tragedy you need to incorporate and
attend to these thoughtfully